I'll talk about sketching there's a -
for algorithmic design so where it is
I'm supposed well this is what the
schedule says in the style of the
previous two overview talks in photos
have been here I know that by now you
expect that I will cancel this title and
talk about something else I have to
disappoint you I'll actually try to talk
about this as much as I can I mean it's
still hard to talk so I'll try to I
guess Robin's selling kind of concrete
problems I'll try to you know sell you
here like more of a perspective about
August design okay this is what we are
trying to go after and let me tell kind
of like one problem you know in
particular kind of I I was working a lot
on working a lot on is the following
kind of problem on no big datasets is
given a bunch of objects in this case
this is a bunch of images taking from
the classical image net data set and you
want to find the pairs of similar
similar objects here okay and you know
there are kind of two issues I mean one
is that there are too many objects here
so pairwise comparison of objects gives
you quadratic quadratic algorithm in the
number of objects but also comparing two
objects might be difficult
takes some amount of time because well I
mean each object has non-trivial
representation and just comparing
objects takes time as well okay so so
kind of this is more of a you know I
guess methodology slide so first of all
kind of you know how are we gonna try to
speed up these kind of problems so first
of all you know how do we represent
images kind of focus on ordering down on
the images case so how are we
representing them well usually we
represent them as some high dimensional
vectors so kind of a most naive way to
represent images is let's say take a
binary vector where each coordinate
corresponds to a pixel of an image and
then comparing two images just continue
completing Hamming distance between
these two two vectors so you feel Maja's
a large these are already kind of high
dimensional vectors and even kind of
competing the distance between
is between these two vectors take some
time proportional to the dimension and
kind of a natural idea to speed up this
task of finding similar pairs and this
is something that is still used in
practice a lot it's basically to do
certain kind of dimension reduction on
on these vectors and let's say for
Hamming for hemic vectors kind of the
most naive dimension reduction is just
subsample a bunch of coordinates compute
the distance the Hamming distance on the
subsample coordinate so you know that
you know it's we subsampled exactly the
same coordinates and this gives some
estimate of the distance okay so kind of
more principal kind of principle if this
is been an example of dimension
reduction and you know what really kind
of you know what you know what are the
properties of these two kind of a
dimension reduction is that it is a form
of compassion of the of the object of so
it is some compressed representation of
the object so we don't remember
everything about the object we cannot
uncompress it so it is lossy and but it
is good for a specific task so it kind
of has a tool for compression and if you
think about this as functional
compression it is good for the specific
task and specific task here is computing
the distance okay so this is this is
kind of one of these tools kind of you
know kind of as a foreshadow of the of
this general kind of sketching ideas all
right I should mention here but you know
nowadays this is not really very
presentation of images with one uses you
know today you pass them through these
black trapezoids right and get vectors
okay to say what does the joke is okay
you really kind of pass them through
neural networks but you know you train
on some training data but at the end of
the day kind of if you if you look at
the neural networks kind of at the day
at the end of the days you have to do
classification so if you look at the
kind of penultimate level then each
image gives you gives a high dimensional
vector and you really need to do
basically what is maximal inner product
to do to find real final class of the or
the image or
okay so this is you know this is kind of
like dimension reduction is one tool but
more generally kind of you know this is
the picture the logic of kind of of this
talk is that more generally what what we
can think about or like what needs to be
you know what you can utilize our 16
data presentations of which dimension
reduction is just one example and we
somehow want to use these 16 data
representations you know perhaps that
you know have some properties of this
sort to design more efficient algorithms
okay and this is you know we'll see some
examples today I'm sure but you know
some of these examples you've seen them
but you know just I want to put it in a
bigger context and kind of motivation
but you know what listen and the ferret
cook threat computer science community
there has been a lot of other ways to do
with 16-bit representations so sketching
a particularly is kind of a natural
computational generalization of a
dimension reduction and generally was
originally proposed in the streaming
community and the rubbers so kind of
more most specialized sampling or metric
embeddings and other methods so I'm
mostly kind of focused on sketching but
you know we should think about this as
there are more ways to to get these
16-bit representations okay so okay so
I'll you know here is the plan now you
know this is way too much kind so talked
about so there is no chance I actually
can cover everything and give like a
fair overview so to kind of give a
disclaimer this is really a random
selection of a few topics that I thought
would be cool to mention kind of and
will be the relevant kind of a few
audience and here can be free things
that I'll mention so one is the medical
in your algebra so hopefully more you
have seen work done here kind of the use
of sketching here to speed up these
algorithms also talk about similarity
search in I starts to do this problem I
should say something about it and also
the talk right after will be very
relevant we'll set up the ground for the
talk after and then I will actually
spend a little bit more time here
which will show how to use kind of
somewhat different sketching for
speeding up a particular linear program
okay so you know I think this is this is
something relevant but I expect that
many of you have not seen it actually
okay so we'll start with one and you
know hopefully many of you have seen
this so this is kind of more of recap so
the problem that we let's say we
consider here is least square regression
so this is we want to find let's say X
star which minimizes this l 2-norm
services where a is a matrix where of
size n by D we'll usually think of as
being much larger than G so these kind
of dimension of vector X and n is kind
of the number of samples and you know
usually think of n being much larger
than D and we will allow approximation
on perception on and this is really what
in that Lee talked about two days ago
right so except that he considered the
LP version okay so I'm certain from the
basic will start from l 2-norm
and the idea here kind of is you know
it's it's termed sketching solve
actually I was asking can the other day
kind of where the time comes from well
I'm not exactly sure but we'll get back
to the name a little later but it is the
following so what we can do is rather
than solving kind of the original
problem we just reduce the dimension of
the problem in a particular reducer a
larger dimension namely the n dimension
so what we do is we pre-multiply both a
and b by a matrix s where s is you can
think about s as a dimension reducing
matrix okay so something will be sort of
Johnson in the Strauss and we think
about reducing your dimension m to be
much much smaller than M you know
ideally perhaps not even depending on
and more like you know proportional to D
or maybe less okay
so this is the idea and so we solve this
you know we don't get precisely X star
but we hope is that the X prime solution
is sufficiently good maybe you know it
we lose a factor of 1 plus Epsilon in
the in the objective value okay so how
to do this and really kind of this idea
I mean this has been used in many papers
there should be 3 dots so I think the
first time it was proposed in a paper by
Thomas our lodge and of a lot more has
been shown in particularly in the paper
by Ken Carson in the audience and if it
would roof also hopefully in the
audience but there are many many
important more papers that we are
working in kind of on similar problems
and using similar tools to to improve
the algorithms but ok let me tell you
exactly what what they are doing so so
what exactly is vc-dimension reducing
matrix so we really kind of it the tool
they you know think about this as a
generalization you know certain way to
generalize dimension reduction so it is
called oblivious of space embedding and
it is a map as which again goes from
dimension and to dimension M such that
for sympathy all of you have seen
dimension reduction kind of classical
Johnson a Travis lemma which says that
if you take random Gaussian matrix and
we vanities dimension reducing and it
preserves all 2 norm up to some
approximation ok so here this is
generalization in the sense of it
doesn't hold for any particular vector
let's say with high probability but it
holds actually for entire subspace okay
a linear subspace let's say of dimension
D and it preserves so in a sense with
high probability it preserves the l2
norm of any point P up to 1 plus epsilon
factor for any point P in the sub
okay so it is something that holds for
the entire subspace okay and I should
mention that you know there are
different ways to use to take this
matrix as kind of the the latest kind of
the guest wants using this oblivious
subspace embedding you can essentially
use it kind of the way that I showed in
a previous slide where just pre multiply
it and and then solve the much reduced
system this will give you Mitchell a run
time which is order of number of
non-zeros in the matrix a plus a term
which depends purely on dimension D and
it is a polynomial dependence on Jian
and absol there is a various speakers
that we've reduced yes mm will be d
squared by epsilon so there are a few
papers that improved what is the exact
dependence of M on G and epsilon but you
know think about this as polynomial in Z
by epsilon and what what is very
embedding election I should just what
so yeah its oh my god I guess you it's
this proper to mention that yeah Michael
come and had the best bound on em in
terms of as a function of D epsilon
notice the exact bound or so and kind of
one way to get s and visas from the
paper by n Clarkson David to drove is to
it's a combination of taking random plus
minus once think about this you know a
form of kind of random Gaussian dr and
combined together with the idea of
common sketch which is really I mean it
was done in a different context in the
kind of streaming community and I mean
it's a sketching algorithm those of you
who I've heard about it but just I give
the point that I'm trying to make here
is that these this map s is really kind
of based on the ideas that came out of
kind of semi committee of sketching
community so so this is you know this is
what you can get from this as the idea
the idea of constructing s kind of is
that multiplying by the linear map s
should be done fast this is why there is
a lot of work in designing this map as
so what it is efficient so it turns out
that you can if you're unhappy with
polynomial dependence in one of our
epsilon it turns out that you can
combine these ideas of oblivia subspace
embeddings together with preconditioning
and this will get you time of this sort
where you have a factor of log of 1 over
epsilon okay so this is kind of this is
roughly kind of you know how things go
in for least square regression so
basically for for l2 norm but
what if we want what if you want to do
l1 regression okay there is a question
so you can compute pre-conditioner for a
using the obvious huh space embedding
you know so you compute the precondition
are kind of so the algorithm doesn't
really work exactly in the way that I
mentioned so you complete the condition
and then you just use violated substance
meaning to compute the precondition
okay so so how did how shallow do we l1
regression so in a sense you know what
we are basing here and for l2 case what
we're basing on is that we can do this
oblivious dimension reduction kind of so
more fancier versions of jerseylicious
lemma so you know one there is no good
dimension reduction l1 so we don't even
hope to do an entire subspace embedding
okay so so this is a problem nonetheless
and again this is was coming from the
streaming or sketching community versus
a result but you're trending who showed
that okay there might be not a dimension
reduction in the classical sense of
dimension reduction but there is a
different object there is a different
way to kind of compress the object so
that we can still recover well one norm
of that object so so this is my sketch
and you can think about this as a
relatively generic definition of what
sketches so it is a linear map again it
is reduces dimension from M to M naught
that is also an estimator e is just a
generic algorithm I mean I guess it's a
specific album in this case such that
for any say for any point P in the
dimensional space we have that the l1
norm is approximated by an estimation
this metal algorithm run on the sketch
of the pointy okay so originally I can
you know what is the difference is that
originally we really cared that these
estimator is just computing the l2 norm
kind of okay so here we're just allowing
kind of an arbitrary algorithm okay and
kind of the rest is you know is exactly
kind of as we expected intimate
reduction a kind of statement where you
have a 1 plus epsilon distortion with
some probability
yes so this is a friendly P of dimension
M here this is this is not inside so
that's what I'm I mean that's what I was
saying and that even I mean even before
doing oblivious subspace in banning you
know we would need you know a result
even for dimension one kind of dimension
one this means that you want to preserve
the l2 norm of one point this is what
judge Slater shouts would give you what
I'm saying for a-1 there isn't an
equivalent statement as Jenson leaders
house even you know even for dimension D
equals one so what this statement I mean
what this sketch is the equivalent of
just little shells think about this as
opposed to this is not really equivalent
of oblivious subspace in Benny and I
should mention kind of what what this
map as looks like so it's a linear map
so you can just take a matrix which is
which has random Cauchy random variables
and so you can use I mean you can use
the ideas based on this to get certain
improved algorithm for one regression
there is actually a slightly different
way to do it and give slightly better
algorithms and think about this as a
form of a let's call it a poor
dimensional reduction if you maybe we
don't get a very good dimensional
reduction but we get a full dimension
reduction which basically is you know
looks more like job little subspace in
bending now except that instead of
getting an A one perception
approximation we're getting a much
larger approximation which is polynomial
in D okay but over something I guess
this is the poor oblivious subspace in
meaning
okay and how we map s who look like so
it is it is a map which you you know
combines ideas of multiplying by one of
our exponential random variables and the
count scheduled I mentioned from the
previous slide that was used for auto so
kind of you know even though you get
this approximation kind of much larger
approximation for doing one oblivious
subspace in bending it turns out that
you can use an iterative method to
reduce the final approximation to 1 plus
epsilon and and what what you can get at
the end of the day is an algorithm that
runs in time which is number of
non-zeros times log n plus something
polynomial in D by Epsilon
ok and I should mention that two days
ago in that talked about giant work with
Michael Cohan and other offers I don't
remember
yes it's unpublished paper sorry and we
if we talk about app for the epsilon
dependence then probably the current
father cell for me is the paper by
microwave with Japan Michael oh ok which
runs it is so of this form I do remember
the running carpet they basically
reduced to a D by T power and then you
use whatever calm so this is I mean but
it is still it should be polynomial in T
by epsilon cancer but you get the
optimal or one day obviously without the
logon I mean the odd morondava I don't
remember they get lot and all maybe
something not Lada I don't remember
so it is right so I mean this is there
are a number of papers that achieve it
by mentioning your result that at least
for L P where P is strictly bigger than
one you can actually get a logarithmic
in one over epsilon dependence but this
is unpublished paper as being taught
about it and so this is kind of you know
the general overview of kind of you know
how things roughly worked for numerical
linear algebra and how we can use
sketching ideas for speeding up
algorithms and I should mention that you
know very much more this is I just want
to kind of give you some kind of
highlights or you know rough of a rough
sketch of how things would go around I
definitely recommend taking a look at
David Woodruff's survey if in FN tDCS
rogue is the also a number of papers
since van that appeared but you can
apply this kind of ideas to many more
problems for longer angle approximation
and as well as optimization and I think
mandolin will talk about low-rank
optimization problems which will use
sketching ideas later today as well as
matrix application and ours okay so so
this is so I bent a little bit quick
through that hopefully because many of
you have seen ideas from there so let me
go further and kind of cover some other
things that you know probably many of
you have seen less of so first
similarity search so this is a legit of
a problem of approximate nearest
neighbor where this is kind of related
to the original problem that I mentioned
so here we need to pre-process and
points we are given us an approximation
see think about C as 1 plus epsilon but
usually we don't think of X was being
too small think of approximation is
being too let's say and the problem is
that pre-process these data sets of a
given a query point q we report the
closest point P star or maybe closest up
to some approximation factor C okay so
this is the nearest
neighbor will actually look at a related
problem of veneer neighbor which is
formally connected to the nearest
neighbor it's just easier to talk about
near neighbor problem where we have a
threshold R so instead of just reporting
the closest point off to some
approximation it is okay to report any
point within distance R from the query
point okay and what it means to be
approximate here the formal definition
of approximate in your neighbor is that
as long as very some point in this green
ball it is okay to report something I
out either from the green ball or from
these I guess no-man's-land
in the gray area okay but it is not not
a key to report something from the red
area okay so this is the formal
definition of approximation and and the
main parameter is that we care about
here is basically the space to store
this data structure plus the query time
how much time does it take to answer
this query hopefully it will take time
which is sub linear in the number of
points okay and basically solving this
data structure is you know basically
related to the best way to solve your
original problem that I mentioned in my
first slide namely finding similar panes
of pairs of points in in a data set of
of objects okay so here kind of the
again focusing on you know like what are
the data representation primitives or
this accent data presentation primitive
so here kind of the tool over idea was
proposed by unique motwani back annotate
and it is termed locality sensitive
hashing how many of you have seen the
definition of this okay about half a
little more so this is you know I'll
define it I mean this will be related to
Moses talk later today but I mean what
is it what it is it is really a random
hash function defined on a high
dimensional that on a high dimensional
space of dimension D
and a random hash function in in
dimension D it can also be thought of as
a random space partition okay so it is
run off a partition because you can
think about each part is being the locus
of the points that have exactly the same
hash code and that this hash function
okay
and generally what we want is a
partition where a closed pair so a
closed pair is you know this is a
example of closed pair formulate is a
pair which is within distance R with our
fresh hold and the similarity threshold
will one be probability but we are in
the same bucket namely the hash codes
are equal is to be high as opposed to
the far point far pair of points namely
Q and it is P prime which are distance
more when CR we want the probability but
they collide have the same hash code to
be small okay and then to solve our
problem we can just build a hash table
this would be the entire solution for
this problem in particular fogies let's
say free point data set you just store
all the buckets and the points in both
buckets and then given a query point Q
you just look up the bucket let's say
this is the bucket and now given these
two conditions this means that the
points in this bucket will be exactly
the points that we want to report namely
the points which are within distance R
and none of the points which are far ok
now this sounds too good to be true
in particular you know you can see that
there are boundaries it is easy to put
points on two sides of a boundary which
are very close yet they are separated so
it is not really possible to obtain this
probabilities very high for any
reasonable threshold R okay so you know
we settle for something you know less
ambitious you say well as long as there
is some gap between these two
probabilities so you know if this is
small maybe this is not so small then we
still bar in game we can still do
something not trivial so this means that
maybe one hash table will not succeed
but maybe you can use a number of hash
tables thank you so pictorially this
means that you will just take a sample a
bunch of these random space partitions
build a hash table for each of them and
then for every query just look for all
the tables
okay and kind of what is the I mean of
course the main object here kind of
remains medical to here is this random
hash function basically this run no
space partition and the quality of our
data structure will depend on the
quality of this random hash function in
particular root it'll depend on is it
will depend on you know how does how
does this profile or the function looks
like so we can draw this function which
is the probability of collision of two
points as a function of the distance
between these points and in particular
you know these two probabilities are two
points on this curve we want them kind
of the gap between these probabilities
to be as large as possible and how do we
exactly measure the gap I mean the you
know should go for calculations and see
how many hash tables do we need to take
and it's basically controls both the
space and the query time you figure out
that you know this is to be the number
of hash tables will be n to some power
raw you know pink row some kind of you
know capacity or quality of this hash
function and it will be a function that
this probabilities P 1 and P 2 it's you
know it's slightly uglier function but
you know this is the right function it's
not too hard to prove it and you know
let me just give you kind of two
examples of LSH maps so the first one is
from data in India America in the Rockne
and basically this is the space the idea
is to just impose a randomly shifted the
rotated grid
ok so pictorially this is let's say your
data set you take a grid you randomly
shift it rotate it and basically this
would be your your partition right so
these are different pockets all these
points have the same code lansing okay
and you can get you know compute what
what you get as the exponent this
function wrong you'll get something like
1 over C where C is the approximation
and I'll just run an example of C equals
2 so for proximation 2 you get the
exponent which is 1/2 so this means the
query time is roughly Rutan
the result that you can do better you
can get an improvement from 1/2
Porter and the idea is the twelve and
partitioning the space into grids
basically into this into cubic cells is
better to partition the space into balls
basically so we cannot really partition
even two-dimensional space perfectly
into balls so you do something like this
so you know picture is worth a thousand
words
this is this is how a partition where
and of these grids of balls are randomly
shifted okay so this is kind of a be
introduced in a paper we had of katrinak
awhile ago okay so this would be a
random partition kind of each colored
connected part is basically a bucket
okay so you know can we do even better
Alice H maps than these random partition
into balls it turns out that no and you
know the the real reason is that it's an
example of pfizer perimetry you can
improve lower bounds and the lower
bounds basically showed that this is the
optimal way to partition space and this
is due tomate one in our opening Rajee
and later do not want you who got the
the tightest bound okay so I just want
you to show this this example I should
mention kind of you know tend to talk
about our stage about mentioning that in
more recent work we actually showed that
you can get better map so you can
basically break through this lower bound
if you allow your run no space
partitions to depend a little bit on the
dataset okay ask me about the talk if
you if you are curious about this it's
not really important for his discussion
but just to state that you know you can
get actually better Ross if you are
interested in this problem but I mean so
as defined a message and if I define it
as a you know a tool to solve nearest
neighbor search but it turns out that
you can use it for much more than a
purely nearest neighbor search so in
particular the applications of obvious
idea of almost natural kind of kind of
outside this problem is too
maximum or minimum inner product so we
have a bunch of vectors and you have any
vector you're going to find the vector
which maximizes or minimizes the inner
product of my query vector sometimes it
comes up as by the name of me problem
and this particular problem is used a
lot in in speeding up certain
optimization algorithms for example
green in coordinate descent cardinal
function approximation in some were due
to been an earlier he mean a while ago
as well as this is relevant for talk
later today to kernel estimation so
later they move this Cherica we'll talk
about how to use local CC Fasching for
faster kernel estimation from define the
problem we'll talk about it and I guess
in the last seven minutes or so I'm the
keeper of time right so that's the
advantage of self introduction so let me
talk about the last part which is about
geometric mean cost match okay so end
kind of again kind of going back on kind
of more like a philosophical level so
far kind of the way we exploited the
sketches or kind of these tools for
suction data presentation is to really
to compress the input all right so so in
some sense there is okay this is like
very you know hand drawing kind of
picture in some sense we have certain
computation to be done let's say for a
least square regression and what we did
we say like well you know maybe we can
promote apply our matrix a and B by is
you know certain dimension reducing
matrix this reduces the size of the
input and once we have smaller matrices
you know it is easier to run you know
standard exact algorithms for example to
get much faster computation but what I'm
trying really to advocate in general is
that we can really think about 16 data
representations also to compress not
just kind of the input but really kind
of the internal state for partial
computations that we have done
you know we might be doing in a problem
so using internals sketches to to
compress in terms of state or partial
computations so so and this is the last
I mean this last bullet point is really
about that okay and let me basically
literally about this so the problem is
the following so it is by chromatic mean
cost matching so given two sets a and B
of size let's say n in in some D
dimensional collinear space we need to
find me in cost matching so this is an
example this problem appears under many
names in image vision to appear by the
name of earthmover distance in math it
usually is called or or it's called
optimal transportation problem or
beseeched and metric and so forth okay
vishay metric of type one alright and
classically know how would you solve
this problem so you know classically you
you can set up and LP to solve this
problem it will have N squared variables
so this is kind of you know an LP one
way to set up this LP so you have pi pi
IJ which says wherever we match point or
how much of a point P I from the red
cell we match to the point J from the
blue set okay the color coding set a is
red and set B is blue okay
and so you know this if you set up our
previous where it is like never mind if
you manage to solve you start at this LP
with van square variables so the best
you can hope for is linear time in N
squared roughly right so actually there
is an upcoming paper by schooler with
and recall a upcoming in nib 17 who
basically showed that you can solve
these LP for arbitrary costs for
arbitrary cost function
in time which is roughly N squared by
some function of epsilon where epsilon
so this is kind of new linear time now
okay this is as fast as we can solve
this we can hope to solve is LP not yeah
not quite but I mean almost but not
quite it's not multiplicative one plus
epsilon so there is a little bit more
factors this is why there is a star here
but you know sorry oh I don't know is
Jason in doings no but yeah I mean there
are more caveats here but I mean we
better talk about them after the after
we talk but really kind of you know here
we can you know oftentimes kind of the
most classical way to use this problem
when it appears an image vision is when
D is equal to two okay so these are
points in two-dimensional space this is
kind of one of the most classical
applications and here were saying like
well our input is really order of and
it's not order of N squared we're not we
can compute all these distances so it
really should hope for something which
is whose run time is much less than N
squared okay so maybe a proportional to
linear in N and this is what I wanted to
mention basically a technique that we
introduced with such a nicola freezing
in the audience to Stefanik and
bridgehead a soft-serve actually half
years ago where we showed that we can
solve this this problem and in general
the transportation optimal transfer
problem in time which is Bucky near
linear will end to 1 plus smaller one
for fixed dimension D and fixed
approximation Epsilon
okay so dependence on option is actually
worse than one polynomial in oliver
episode but you know for fixed ones you
can get this amount of time and well we
we called our framework solvent sketch
this is different from the first thing
that I mentioned which was called sketch
and solve and I know it's it's a nice
job but it
was really independent names as far as I
know it is yes
so this is what I wanted to mention kind
of these you know basically this
dissolution okay so how how do we do it
and really you should think about this
is a some very fancy divide and conquer
algorithm okay to solve to solve this
problem being minkos matching okay and
this is how you know it works first of
all you have to do divide so somehow
we'll take the problem we partition it
to three basically not not to give three
and we'll try to solve the problems
recursively and then recombine them
until kind of at the top will have the
solution okay so this partitioning will
be you know related to kind of
relatively classic kind of geometric
partitions of the space but you know
what we want to do is we take we want to
take the space and partition it somehow
hierarchically in a nice way okay so let
me use this kind of intuitive let the
moment and non formally but think about
LSH type partitions would be good and
this is kind of one way to partition the
points I just draw you know a number of
points not everywhere but you can think
about this like red partition is like an
a first-level partition and then these
small blue partitions are kind of
second-level partitions okay
so this is okay this is part one now now
what do we do in each part so in each
part what we try to do is the following
we try to compute so let's say in this
part so you can think about you know
each of these parts will correspond to
each of the smaller parts will
correspond each of these Leafs in this
computation to in this divide and
conquer so this is kind of one way to
see it okay so what we'll try to do is
compute the local solution in each of
its parts okay so maybe this is the
local solution in each other parts right
so this is kind of partial matching as
much as we can then then what we do is
with scheduling solutions so we cannot
really you know
recombining this kind of at the top you
know is this harder solving the entire
problem so what we're trying to do is
actually just compress what has happened
here into something I guess
kind of stars this will be some sketches
and then at this node this computational
node will just be recombining the these
sketches were to obtain here to form a
more global solution and if a more
global matching and of these will
correspond to merchants across the parts
in the first level okay and I guess you
know and then you sketch whatever you
obtain you know some weird they're
object and then you send it up in the
conversation thing okay
and of course you know but what exactly
needs to be a software like what are the
main you know things that we need to
discuss you know how do we partition the
space in her hierarchically how do we
compute this solution for the local view
so that we can recombine it later into a
global solution how to sketch the
solution these are and of the main
things to be done and so you know
applying this this particular framework
for the row geometric matching problem
so this you know partition of a space
you know any reasonable partition will
work let's say randomly shifted
quadtrees relatively classic idea for
this kind of problems will work but the
first you know the first thing where we
run into a problem is computing a local
solution for the problem so just to give
you kind of an intuition of what's
happening well so this is you know grid
these red grids is the partition of a
problem okay so each cell kind of is a
different part so now in the first level
we need to solve the problem given the
local view so this means that we see a
bunch of red points some blue points
there might be outside points outside we
don't know about them we just need to
solve these kind of subproblems and I
feel for me that they cannot really
compute a local solution so that you can
patch it with the rest of a problem
later into a good global solution and
this is the reason so suppose you take
you know you see this you see this point
so you say like well given these points
that I see them the best way to match
them is well pretty much this you know
if there is nothing else this is the
best matching but then you know somehow
you know the next level
you know we uncover everything else and
we need to recombine this with the rest
of your points and it turns out that we
should have taken exactly the opposite
alternation so and once we have
committed to this kind of matching there
is no way I mean this should be the
right way to do the min-cost matching
and once we have committed to the wrong
alternation kind of to be wrong matching
there is no way to patch it up later to
get boot approximation right so once we
have committed to this matching there is
no way to do you know to fix it to get
an approximation which is close to 1
plus Epsilon to get an approximation
less than 2 so really what we need to do
here is not to computed just one
solution here for the local view what
would you really need to do is to
compute all potential solutions that are
valid solutions given well what will
happen later in the other parts ok so
let me just define exactly what that
means
so sketching all solutions this is
roughly how it will look like so so
you'll define something which are called
portal points so in a sense think about
this as you know we have you know you
can think about the matching as a flow
kind of problem and you're saying that
well when we're matching let's say
points and cross these boundaries we
really should route them through this
portal points is big axis so we're
saying that once we kind of have this
cell and we want to match something from
this cell to something outside the cell
we are not allowed to go directly you
have to go through this portal so there
is kind of entry and exit points into
the cell okay and the advantage of these
of doing this is that we can define a
very you know small something which will
depend on epsilon only number of such
portal points ok and now we can define
the following solution function so
solution function is a function which
maps from something of dimension K into
positives and basically for any input X
of dimension K we define f of X to be
the following so assume that there is
you know we specify what is the amount
of flow in and out for each other
pulse and you're saying assuming that
this is the amount of flow that Gaussian
or outside of each of a portal what is
the best solution of the matching with
the points that are inside this part so
in you can think about these X is
defining the interface and you're saying
the solution function is a function from
the interface to the optimal solution
another idea is to sketch this function
f and it turns out that you can sketch
with the entire function f ok and the
size will be something like logarithmic
log n by epsilon 2 power K so in
particular it will get in exponential in
1 over F so independence it's not
particularly good but I don't know if
this is optimal or not and perhaps one
can do better but given such skills you
can estimate this function of the 1 plus
epsilon approximation so
it is a form of course I mean I see
corsets as a type of sketch so just for
me the question is much much it is I
mean you can think about this as a
corset but this sketch is really I mean
corsets are usually take a subset of
your dataset kind of if you it's not a
subset of it it's evaluation of F on
certain points on some geometric
discretization of your input space yes
precisely precisely you can take that
and you can patch it with things that
are outside and it is presented okay so
the overall algorithm we kind of you
know at the next level you need to
recompose with sketches into kind of a
sketch of a solution and I think the
combined region and it turns out that
you can formulate this as some linear
program actually so at each of is know
that the under videos will be solving it
will be solving a small linear program
and so just to interpret this what it
happened what happens is that you take
this LP that corresponds to by chromatic
matching you decompose it into kind of
in this hierarchical fashion into many
smaller piece so each of these tangles
would be an LP of small size so really
you can just solve both LPS with any
polynomial time solver and you'll get
the stated time which would be basically
nearly an even number of points okay and
okay this is this is it
so I'll finish here I guess the main
point that I wanted to mention is that
[Music]
we can think about 16 theta
presentations as certain kind of objects
that I mean the definition is kind of
problem specific for different problems
you might have different properties and
you know there are different ways to get
the 16 that representations are mostly
mentioned dimension reduction in
sketching but there are other ways as
well kind of based on the symmetrical
bindings or sampling and to use these
succeded representations to get
efficient algorithms and I give you
three examples but this is just a very
small selection of the ways that we can
use these 16 that representations
to speed up auditions and I'll end here
thank you questions
if not then I guess we reconvene at
10:45 for the next talk